today I'll be giving a talk on why
software engineers disagree about
everything okay
my name is deceive Qureshi I'm a
software engineer at Airbnb I work on
the wrist team I'll be talking a lot
more about that and a lot more about
kind of my own history and the different
different things that I've done in my
past because that really informs a lot
of what this talk is about I don't know
that I'll totally answer the question of
why software engineers disagree about
everything but I think this talk is
gonna be kind of an exploration of this
question from a number of different
angles and another things can happen in
this talk is I'm going to disagree
pretty strongly with DHHS keynote so if
so that might be interesting but we'll
hopefully at the very least if not
convince you of what I'm saying you know
maybe get you thinking about some things
so this talk in large part is going to
be about philosophy so I know you know
to railsconf usually people come up here
and they talk about controllers or I
guess someone else is talking about
sorting and augmented reality I'm not
gonna be offended if you get up right
now and one or two another talk that's
really cool but we are gonna go way into
the weeds today because that's that's
what I'm all about
so specifically I want to talk about the
field of philosophy known as mr. Malla g
and epistemology the easiest way to
define epistemology is epistemology is
the nature of knowledge of justification
and of the rationality of belief so this
actually this diagram here is of
phrenology which is this old science of
you know try to figure out what parts
the brain responsible for what which is
a very old and ancient version of
epistemology which we've now thankfully
displaced but centrally in epistemology
are there are the two questions how does
anyone know anything and how do they
know that they know it I mean these two
questions are kind of navel-gazing but
that's that's fine so let me tell you
look about me so I studied English and
Philosophy in school and I before I ever
came in the tech world I used to be a
professional poker player I did that for
about five years
you know I kind of took a very different
path into programming than most people
and then I worked as a programming
instructor I taught programming at a
coding boot camp and for the last little
bit over a year I've been working as an
engineer on the RISC team at Airbnb
basically fighting fraud and so because
of this I've kind of you know snaked my
way through many different subcultures
I've been something of a of a chameleon
in that I've learned the different norms
and the different beliefs and the
different knowledge systems that many
different worlds have and try to assert
on you if you become a part of that
world
and one thing that I've noticed and then
you can't help but notice the more of
worlds you step in and out of is that
knowledge is deeply cultural so in the
world of programming you know the kind
of things you might hear people tell you
when you come into this world they might
tell you that full set javascript is the
future they know this for sure they'll
tell you that everyone should know see
if you don't know see what are you doing
go out there you crack open the book and
learn some see they'll tell you rust is
the best language for systems
programming they'll tell you that
relational databases don't scale they'll
tell you that TDD is a fantasy and
nobody's serious tries to do it anymore
it's it's not it's not practical so now
all these are interesting questions
they're all things that people disagree
on obviously but they're people they're
things that people hold with very very
strong conviction that this is clearly
and just beautifully true now I'm not
interested in convincing you of any of
these claims each of these could
probably be great talks themselves what
I'm interested in is why we disagree
about them why isn't that we all
converge on an answer to these questions
now it's funny because when I was in the
poker world I remembered this this was
very familiar to me when I was learning
how to be a poker player because in the
poker world people will tell you things
like No Limit is dying you have to learn
mix games or they would tell you
everybody needs to use a HUD or they
would say only fish play lose passive
Styles they would say GTO is a fantasy
nobody actually plays like that and
there's a wonderful analogy between
these these two worlds not doesn't that
people argue a lot and then people are
maybe kind of wine
excessive but that you know they're
there all these things that people
fundamentally disagree on and each side
of them holds tremendous conviction that
their side is clearly and obviously
correct and so when most people hear
stuff like this when they hear someone
say hey everybody should know see and if
you don't know it see you're not a real
programmer their natural reaction is oh
god is that true if that's true what
should I do about it but I for me having
having gone through this song and dance
so many times my reaction is why do they
think they know that and why what is it
that implanted so much confidence in
them so much conviction that the thing
they're saying is actually true and
universally true and that's very
interesting to me it's almost like I'm
asking I tend to ask a more evolutionary
question than a question about the world
as it is right now you know the thing
that's kind of weird about programming
in particular is that nobody agrees you
know there's so many things that people
disagree on they disagree about
functional programming object-oriented
programming TV be all you know robust
proven frameworks shiny new ones that
solve new problems in different ways
serverless event-driven blah blah blah
right you guys you guys know all this
nobody agrees why that's really weird
now you might think it's obvious that
people don't agree that's that's an
understandable reaction you might say
like well you know disagreement is a
normal part of a society and like you
know the way that we you know this this
divergence is a source of discourse and
that's what we end up having a healthy
society so you might think that's
obvious so of course people shouldn't
agree I think it's weird I think it's
weird that people don't agree and I want
to develop in you and intuition to also
believe this is weird that people don't
agree because in a way it makes more
sense for people to agree than for them
to disagree another way of putting what
I'm saying is that systems in general
tend to converge when you see a system
you should assume that over time it's
going to converge on what's optimal
what's the sort of the optimal state for
that system
let me give you an example um so I'm
gonna give you the example related to
poker but you don't need to know
anything about poker in order to
understand us I can explain it in a
couple sentences so in poker there's a
strategy called set mining ok and some
money is very simple so in Texas Hold'em
you get two cards and if you want to set
mine what you do is you wait for two
cards that make a pair so let's say you
get dealt a pair of threes then what you
do is you wait to see if you make three
of a kind you make you have a kind you
bet it really aggressively and if you
don't need to fold that's set money
super super simple to set my name with a
strategy that was pretty simple and
pretty stupid almost anybody could do it
and it worked it worked really really
unreasonably well given how simple the
strategy was and so pretty soon what you
would see in the world of online poker
is that pretty soon when people started
talking about this almost everybody
started set mining at low to mid stakes
for ring and the strategy took over like
wildfire and well you could say is that
the game converged on set miner
everybody saw that set mining was the
high ground and they all moved in that
direction and so this is this is kind of
one of the features that happened to
poker after internet poker trick Rob's
internet poker took off really around
2004-2005 maybe a little bit before that
as well and if you think about it before
internet poker ever existed there was
live focus right playing poker in a
brick-and-mortar casino and live program
was fundamentally really different than
online poker in ways that people didn't
really predict before it happened so you
can imagine live poker you know let's
say in the 80s and 90s you know there
are some people playing poker out in
Phoenix maybe there are people playing
poker in Vegas there people playing
poker in Dallas people playing poker in
London and these different groups of
poker players weren't really
communicating with each other you know
ideas that were germinating in London
weren't you know going over the pond and
showing up in card rooms in Dallas right
people were kind of isolated to their
little groups and they were just playing
poker and figuring things out as they
went but with the advent of online poker
and the communication that it enabled
for a lot of people sorry there was like
a fire with the advent of that
communication what happened was that it
allowed the system to converge where
suddenly somebody has an idea for
strategy somewhere in you know Dallas or
New Hampshire or whatever and suddenly
they can share it and everybody can
learn about this strategy very very
quickly and so what this meant was that
the the state of poker strategy for a
long time it was pretty static the way
that people played in the 40s and 50s
was not that different than the way
people play it in the 80s and 90s you
know information just wasn't able to
evolve that effectively but with the
advent of online poker
suddenly if you if you look at the curve
of the complexity of Poker strategy it
just it just takes off right after 2003
when online poker comes to town and so
right here is a graph that audio is not
playing but that's fine he's saying look
at this graph this is a joke that didn't
play audio that's fine we're gonna roll
with it so this is actually a graph this
is actually just a graph that goes up
into the right there's nothing to what
I'm talking about but I thought it would
give a sense of legitimacy to the slides
like oh this guy knows who's talking
about this graph
cool so the point is the point is all
I'm hoping converged in a way that that
live poker never did it was never able
to and this to me is it makes a lot of
sense like of course online poker is
going to converge right when you have
these people able to communicate to see
what each other is doing and move around
in this terrain of course they're gonna
settle on what's optimal and nature is
full of convergent systems like this so
you know let's say for example you're
you're walking down town and you you buy
a loaf of bread
maybe you're French I don't know and
let's say you you eat half a loaf of
bread you toss the rest on the street
well what happens is pretty soon a bunch
of pigeons just from it's not like
they're all in one place standing over
watching you throw the loaf of bread
right but pretty soon one pigeon comes
three pigeons come and then a chorus of
pigeons from presumably all over town
just come in and start you know just
just binging on the piece of bread that
you've left and this this kind of make
sense right like the pigeons are able to
very quickly come down to whatever's the
OP
no place for them to be they they eat as
much food as they can and they disperse
back to wherever was they came from
maybe to the next best piece of food or
they can find somewhere downtown this
example of a convergent system so you
know there's also this great Rammstein
album that actually I loved when I was a
kid it's actually just cell membrane in
German because that was only I could
find like 10 minutes ago but the the
cell membrane you guys might remember
from high school chemistry you know
there are water molecules on one side
they permeate through this membrane and
pretty soon you're the exact same
pressure the exact same density of water
molecules on each side the membrane
system converges and you see the same
sort of thing in stock markets a lot of
natural phenomena and it seems like this
sort of thing is everywhere so when I
started working as a risk engineer at
Airbnb working in the fraud space
naturally I started looking for
convergence too because this seems like
one of those things that any any
sufficiently a complex system should
eventually have some optimal state and
it should find convergence so working in
in in the fraud industry is is its own
little subculture its own little world
and the simple is not just the
subculture of people working against
fraud which is which is interesting but
that wasn't really what fascinated me so
much I mean it is very interesting but
the really fascinating thing about
fighting fraud is that you're actively
fighting against a community of people
you're actively fighting against a
culture that's optimized to take you
down and to basically exploit your
defenses as effectively as they possibly
can and so you know really there is
actually a subculture that I can't see
and don't have direct access to that's
organizing and trying to attack all
these you know major online companies
and they're trying to make money and
that's really interesting
and so I wondered you know how do
fraudsters figure out what to do I mean
what they're what they're learning is
pretty non-trivial right like they're
learning at a script how to do you know
sometimes cross-site request forgery
stuff XSS whatever the the comb with all
these different ways to try to probe our
defenses and attack
and ideally try to make some money how
do they learn this and how do they
communicate this to each other you know
how does how does this knowledge spread
in the world of fraud fundamentally the
question I want to ask is is there
convergence in fraud and this actually
pretty soon after the new MacBook Pro
replace the Escape key we saw a fraud go
way up
that was one person laughter that was
all right there we go there we go a
little just a little bit that's all I
need in order to keep going awesome so I
just want to run with you through a
quick example of kind of what a standard
fraud scheme looks like this is this is
some site called chipmunk does anyone
know what chipmunk is anyone familiar
with this for this esteemed company
great then we're gonna we're gonna [ __ ]
on them that's great so [ __ ] monkey
let's say they cut some corners they
kind of maple at a feature they don't
really know exactly you know they're not
really thinking about frog when they
implement this right like some product
manager is like hey you know we've got
the story we got to get up the end of
the week we're gonna all look good once
we fill this thing out great engineers
who work on this just push it out don't
really think too much about it
so this feature is essentially some
micro deposit where essentially they
verify that you own this account because
you they deposit to rain amounts you
report them back right pretty standard
for some financial institutions to do
this sort of thing so let's say that
they don't implement rate limiting easy
things overlooked well you know they go
to sleep at night feeling great that
they've launched its new feature and
pretty soon someone gets alerted you
know let's say at 2:00 a.m. that night
that somehow we've lost a hundred
thousand dollars which really should not
have happened and the only way you could
lose that amount of money obviously is
if fraudsters are at scale repeatedly
hitting this API repeatedly micro
depositing money into their account and
then just keeping it
and so people scramble you know people
oh my god I can't believe this going on
they go and they try to patch this hole
implement some rate limiting do some
rules maybe reverse whatever
transactions they can this is a common
type of attack that you know a very easy
vector that if you're a site influenced
something like this I kind of attack you
would be vulnerable to if you didn't
implement
rate limiting so let's say they get that
under control that's fine
now what happens is that once you pass
that vulnerability of course the
fraudsters dispersed they don't keep
hitting it maybe they maybe they try to
verify that in fact it is patched they
try a few ways around it doesn't work
cool you've patched the vulnerability
and the fraudsters dispersed but kind of
like the pigeons they don't just go
randomly to different places and just
kind of either leave your platform what
is happening is that they then go to the
next best place to defraud you
so we'll do so fine okay that end point
wasn't that good but there's this other
thing that we can do like this maybe
longer more complex or more expensive
fraud scheme and we're gonna go do that
and basically what you see is that the
fraudsters head down to the next highest
peaks in this terrain of fraud which you
know this this totally makes sense this
is uh this is convergent behavior right
that's exactly what you'd see if the
terrain suddenly changes peak became a
valley and they would go towards the
next highest peak
so this seems to me like converging
behavior seems like fraudsters converge
on what's optimal but the more I thought
about this the more I realized that this
didn't totally make sense and the reason
that this totally didn't make sense
because I asked the question why are
they defrauding us at all why are any
fraudsters attacking chipmunk this might
seem like a weird question right look of
course they're doing it so they can make
money and that's what fraudsters are
motivated by what if you think about it
the the terrain of all the companies
that they can defraud is huge there are
many many many companies that are
vulnerable to fraud and pretty much all
of these companies experience fraud to
one degree or another right there are
all these different sites that you could
attack if you so wanted and so what you
would what do you what you can say is
that there's some topology to that fraud
right there are some peaks and valleys
there's some there's some sites that are
really really lucrative to defraud and
other ones that you know really not so
much and and they're not a good place to
be spending your time if you're a
fraudster and so you'd think that
everybody would converge on the peaks
what you think is that almost all the
fraud would go towards the very most
profitable most attackable websites but
what you see instead is that fraud is
just kind of dispersed everywhere
they're just sort of ambient level of
fraud
if you start an e-commerce site chances
are you're gonna get the sell amount of
fraud why this is weird this should
strike you as weird why is it those
fraudsters just don't care about
optimizing are they not trying to make
the best use of their time is there
something that they're misapprehend
about the terrain what's going on that
we don't see this conversion behavior
within fraud now you know it occurred to
me that actually you see the same sort
of thing in software you know even just
looking at open source solutions there's
so many different software packages
there's so many different open-source
solutions to many many different
problems that are effectively you know
trying to do the exact same thing why if
you like software doesn't converge
either well you don't get this just one
okay this is the best way to solve this
problem and everybody converges on that
solution what you see instead is many
many many competing solutions and it's
not really clear which one is supposed
to win and when one does win it's
actually really surprising you know like
so you know react you could say kind of
one front end UI's insofar as you can
say anyone want front anywise and we're
genuinely amazed by that on some meta
levels like well [ __ ] someone won no one
ever wins anything anymore but react
just one front end you eyes you know and
you know maybe maybe that kind of
relaxes you these are like oh hey you
know as long as they learn react I'll
just be employable forever and you know
that's fine but I think this is this is
somewhat counterintuitive that more
things aren't like this why is this such
a rare story that react wins or sequel
wins or one particular way of solving a
problem just is clearly the best and we
all adopt it so you might have an
obvious objection to this analysis which
would be that well of course you know
things aren't going to converge because
software doesn't just solve one problem
right the obvious answer is that there
are actually multiple terrains so you
know you could say that there's a
terrain for products and that looks
different and there's a terrain for the
payments backends and then one for
social networks and maybe the tools and
the solutions that you use for these
different apps are different and that's
why you see this this you know
these multifarious solutions to
effectively the same problem but I I
don't think that's that's efficient
because even within a single terrain you
don't see convergence you know even just
looking at credits right perhaps aren't
you know they're the majority of what
people build that's a majority of web
apps are just you know glorified credits
maybe with like elasticsearch there on
top and like because of the vast
majority of what people build there's a
vast majority of what people disagree on
so it doesn't seem to me like that's
satisfactory to explain why we don't see
convergence and the thing is you should
want convergence convergence is actually
good because convergence means that we
all see the underlying terrain we all
understand it and therefore we all go
and do the best thing in the world of
software for the most part we're not
actually competing with each other we're
actually all kind of at least to some
degree or another motivated by each
other succeeded you know when someone
invents a great open source solution
actually everybody benefits from that
and most software kind of works this way
so the question I want to ask is why do
these systems not converge
I think there are four reasons and I'm
going to go through each them so the
first reason why these systems don't
necessarily converge is because the
terrain is actually unstable the terrain
is changing it's not just one
configuration that you can just see it
or see something out in the distance
decide okay that's a peak I'm gonna go
over that right the fact that the
terrain is changing means that you're
not really sure if you do go in this
direction that by the time you get there
the terrain isn't going to be different
right it also needs of course that your
terrain is moving underneath you so by
the time that you when you originally
came into Ruby on Rails
I thought wow this is the hottest newest
shiniest web framework anyone has ever
come up with and now it's 2017 and rails
is not the shiniest newest coolest
framework that anyone has ever come up
with
and so the terrain has changed
underneath you and that makes it hard
for people to actually converge when
there's so much change going on there
was this article that someone wrote on
medium a little while back how it feels
to learn JavaScript in 2016 you didn't
read this article I'm sure you have an
intuition of what this thing said right
and we we see this coming more and more
I don't want to say a problem but more
and more of a characteristic of software
that things are changing very rapidly
and it might be that that pace of change
is even increasing which wouldn't be
wouldn't be that unreasonable to expect
actually as technology grows more and
more rapidly and you see the same sort
of thing in the world of fraud so say
for example that you know Facebook has
some kind of hole some kind of things
that fraudsters can attack let's say it
comes really easy to spam Facebook and
you know do some kind of referral click
fraud whatever whatever stuff so maybe
you know if you're a fraudster you're
making $20 an hour defrauding Facebook
doing this well Facebook goes in and
they patch the hole and now you know
instead of making $20 an hour you can we
make $3 now but in order for the
fraudsters to disperse and find the next
highest thing you know they they they
might be just incentivized to say like
hey I don't actually know how easy it's
gonna be to defraud anything else
because that might get patched to and
that might you know the Train might just
change out underneath me you know what
I'll just keep defrauding Facebook for
$3 an hour that's fine like
this is working during the time that I
have it so maybe that's that some part
of the explanation why you don't see
this optimizing across across this rain
so the second reason why I think you see
a lack of convergence in some of these
domains is because of high switching
costs okay so let's say that this is the
domain that the software this is the map
of the software world and let's say that
you live all the way on the bottom right
and the bottom right let's say is rails
land and you know you go and talk to
some wide eyed bushy tail developer who
tells me you know what you you just need
to learn Haskell and if you learn
Haskell you know all these type errors
and nil checks I'm not it out all that
stuff is just gonna go away and you were
gonna live in a land of just pure
programming bliss nothing will ever go
wrong your code will be way more
performant you know you are just gonna
yeah whatever things are gonna be great
the problem with that of course is that
for you to actually engage that switch
let's say even you see what this person
tells you and you agree with them but
this peak that they're pointing to is
very very far away so in order for you
to get there you have to go down into a
valley to reverse a really really long
space until you can finally actually
reap the fruits of what they were
claiming was so great and who knows
because the terrain is changing by the
time you get there it might not even be
a peak anymore something else might have
become peak or maybe the place where you
were at could have become a peak who
knows and so this this instability of
this uncertainty makes people really
unwilling to incur the risk of
traversing the terrain and exploring you
see of course the same thing in fraud
this I just mentioned with the Facebook
example and this whole thing of course
is exacerbated by specialization the
more specialized you are the harder is
going to be for you to convince yourself
to engage in those high switching costs
right there's really specialization is
just basically you finding your way to
some local maximum that's what
specialization is it's climbing as high
as you can onto a local maximum once
you're there
it just becomes really uncompelled to
climb all the way down from that peak of
specialization you've arrived at to go
find the true global maximum which might
be very far away and you know we've
already talked about the fact that it's
changing and uncertain and so this
harder the more specialized we are same
thing with fraudsters they're fraudsters
who are specialized and you know
attacking one side as opposed to another
and it's hard for them to switch after
we learn a lot of new things I had to
start over in their knowledge so as a
third reason why I think you don't see
convergence in fraud or in software or
and these other fields is information
sharing is a very important part of how
you get convergence right if you think
about it not all of us can actually
clearly elusively see that underlying
terrain you know there are these peaks
and valleys we know they're there but
they're sort of like a fog of war right
and then we can't see just kind of
beyond our local environment
you just don't know a month not much
about what Haskell Mountain looks like
or what you know some other language or
framework that you're not familiar with
so in order for us to really get that
sense of where the terrain is like we
have to share information with each
other about what the terrain is that's
that's how we learn what happens if we
go out far enough into the terrain and
whether the costs are going to be worth
it so different cultures have different
amounts of information sharing and that
makes it harder or easier for them to
converge on different things so if you
if you imagine this if you imagine a
graph of different cultures you can sort
of graph them on how closed versus open
they are in terms of information sharing
so if you look at a very very closed
system a good example of this is the
fraud industry so if you're a fraudster
then actually it's very hard to learn
and get access to the information that
you need in order to learn how to become
a fraudster right so they're all these
underground fraud industry so fraud is
an industry in many places in the world
where basically you can you can you know
get access to courses you can buy them
you can get primers on how to hack this
site or that site you there various
tools that you can buy you can pirate
whatever there's all this stuff you need
to get up and running as a fraudster and
it's not easy to get this stuff you
actually have to you know make your way
into communities you have to prove
yourself you have to gain reputation you
can't just decide hey you know I'm gonna
go on Amazon and buy a text book on how
to commit fraud right it doesn't exist
you can't do that you have to go in
through a very specialized way and not
all information is actually readily up
for grabs there are some fraud rings
they just don't share that information
with anyone outside of it and it's not
for sale and so that makes it very
difficult if yours
somebody who's wanting to learn more
about fraud to actually figure out what
is the optimal place for me to be
spending my time defrauding people now
somewhat more on the open side is you
could look at a world like poker
so poker is kind of a more open system
you know so they're all these forums
there are different places where people
can exchange ideas
there's certainly books written about
poker that you can just buy if you want
to but the very best players the very
best ideas the very best theories and
strategies about poker they're generally
not for sale you know the people who
hold them in the people who profit the
most from them tend to keep them close
to the chest so you get a lot of you get
a lot of resources that are okay or that
are really crappy that are openly
available but the very best stuff
sometimes is hard to find and hard to
actually gain value from and then the
other hand if you look all the way to
the right you find software the world
software is in a lot of ways kind of
staggeringly open you know you have
companies that are just releasing the
source code for their entire application
or security libraries that are again
like completely open source and
companies will say yeah we use open SSL
Ruby if you find a weakness in open SSL
that's a weakness in us right and this
is this is really about as open as you
can get and their blog posts there are
all these things that are shared about
about software that make it seem like
wow there's an enormous amount of
information sharing that should really
make it so that people see really
quickly what is actually the best
solution for any different problem
somehow in the world of software it
doesn't really seem like that happens
all that well and so I don't know I
think there's somewhat of an open
question of even though there is a lot
of sharing on the surface if in fact
there are some things that people aren't
that open about sharing like you know I
think when it comes to what a lot of
large companies are doing when there's
sorts putting together a lot of open
source solutions to solve problems they
actually don't immediately go out and
tell people oh hey we solve this problem
here is how we did it
very often the way that companies share
this information is pretty selective and
pretty strategic and the moment you
solve a cutting-edge problem you
generally don't go out and share it
unless you think there's some strategic
value in doing so and so that I think to
some degree kind of exacerbates the
problem of why is it that we don't get
this convergence in the world of
software
it's a reason number four and I think
this is a really interesting reason that
kind of goes to sociology is basically
the problem of group identities and we
heard some this morning about bhh from
DHS about the value of group identities
and I'm kind of gonna go at it from a
complete different angle I'm going to
talk about more the dangers of group
identities so you can imagine that the
world of programming is kind of you know
it's demarcated these different kind of
arbitrary groups okay and one of the
groups might be Rubeus or you know rails
programmers or whatever which you can
either you gotta guys myself in there
then you know you have java lovers over
here - Easter's over here and then
Scala's over there and it's their
dependency special norms that dictate
what you can do inside these different
worlds if you want to fit in into these
groups you know these groups kind of say
like well you're a java lover you can
explore this area but you're not really
you don't really feel so go over there
that's kind of weird stuff that we don't
really do in Java man right and so you
get these kind of arbitrary cuts across
the terrain that make it hard for you to
just freely traverse and explore this
terrain without violating some kind of
social norm associated with your group
turns out you get the same kind of thing
with fraud rates right so there's a
fraud ring that just the frauds Facebook
that's all they do and all they do is
that you know they're they're talking on
some sort of you know secret channel
where only fraudsters that are part of
this group can communicate and they
share information about just how to
defraud uber or just how to defraud
Google and if you're one of the members
of the other groups maybe you can't get
into that group maybe there's just the
process or just decided nope we're with
this group and you're that group and
you're not going to get our information
and so if you want to explore you only
get to explore the Train over there you
know and I think in the world of
software you kind of see this when you
know instead of having like an
explanation a blog post it's just here's
how Kafka works there's the blog post
cough cough or rails engineers right or
the blog post you know X Y Z for
rubyists and this again is like kind of
reinforcing that demarcation that hey
you know I know you want to go to
explore that stuff let me show it to you
in the way that's appropriate for our
group and I think this is really
fascinating to me because you know being
he's relatively new to the subculture of
software I can immediately recognize
this behavior and I think it's pretty
well explained by this theory in
psychology called social identity theory
so the idea of social identity theory
it's pretty simple
essentially suggests that the way that
we construct our identities as human
beings is largely as a result of the
groups that we adhere to so this is kind
of those in several stages the first
thing you do is you start categorizing
the world into social groups okay so you
first have to say okay so these people
are the Christians these people are the
Goths these people are the meatlovers
okay whatever whatever you want to how
do we want to draw up those boundaries
in the space of what people can be so
first you have to draw those boundaries
next you have to identify which of those
groups you belong to you know do I want
to be what do I want to be meat lover do
I want to be a pastor do I want to be
somebody who loves red or whatever you
have to decide which of those groups
you're gonna I that if I was okay then
once you do that the last step is social
comparison now you have to do the pretty
hard work of deciding why the other
groups are bad and your group is good
you have to make this distinction
between your in-group and the out group
and invent some kind of story or
narrative that goes along and reinforces
why you are good and they're bad so you
know there are all these classic
examples of this sort of thing where
basically there's some arbitrary
distinction that you've arrived on as
being important to your social
identification and you know there's no
intrinsic reason why that should be
important but you know where Rubeus and
their java lovers and because of that
they're bad and we're good and we have
to come up with some sort of story why
that's the case and they have to do the
exact same thing now you might be the
social identity theory would suggest
that okay well that should mean that all
rubyists and all rails developers are
the same but I don't really feel like
that I'm not the same as the people
around me
and if you look around people right like
you know you all don't look like a
completely homogeneous group of people
and this is this is true and so there's
this other theory that kind of
complements its really well and it's
called differential psychology a
differential psychology essentially
examines the way that people within
groups
try to make themselves different from
each other as a way of somehow
strengthening their bond is being a part
of that group so for example if you ever
seen the movie West Side Story so you
look at these characters they're all
part of a gang in West Side Story and
they all you know they they're all
together part of the same group and you
can tell they could've have a look right
if you just saw these people in straight
you think okay these people are doing
something together there's some
something that somehow unites them but
notice they don't all wear exactly the
same outfit and they could they could
all wear the exact same outfit they
could all style their hair the exact
same way but they don't
why don't they why don't they do that
you'd think that maybe that would
strengthen their group identity if they
all literally did the exact same thing
they would be a stronger part of that
group but it turns out there's something
intrinsic to us as human beings that
even though we're a part of groups it's
important for us to differentiate
ourselves we actually spend a
significant amount of energy just
differentiating ourselves within the
groups that we're in as a way of almost
masking our identities within that group
right and so we did not make ourselves
feel that like hey I don't have any
identity outside this group because I
seem to be wearing these accident think
everyone else is wearing and doing the
exact same thing everyone else is doing
will expend a lot of energy in order not
to feel that so that's exactly what you
see these people in West Side Story
doing and so I want to draw a little bit
of analogy here is that there's
something kind of similar going on when
you look at something like this where
we're expending this energy you know if
you imagine this underlying terrain of
you know software and let's say this
right here is rails mountain there's a
lot of energy going into making it so
that you know it kind of looks like
we're exploring this big terrain really
everything is actually still in the
bounds of this group even though we're
talking about you know Kafka or elixir
or whatever it is we're still keeping
you as a part of this group and that
identity is actually reinforced by you
being here in every single way even the
fact that you're going to these
different talks talking about different
echnology you're still seeing it as a
rails developer and I think this is bad
I think it's masks the severity of the
problem of social identities making it
harder for us to actually converge and
actually find what is genuinely optimal
it allows us to kind of distract
ourselves in the story but like hey
we're exploring these different
really underlying it we're not so I
think we should really want to find
convergence we should want to find the
true global maximum
so as software engineers what what ought
we to do about this and I don't know
that I have perfect answers to this I
think these are all really intrinsically
hard problems but I do have a couple of
pieces of advice that hopefully might be
instructive to some degree so the first
piece of advice is an adage from paul
Grammer and initially where he said keep
your identity small and really kind of
what this means is to as much as you can
as much as as possible
jettison the labels that you've that
you've very easily come to identify
yourself with and so that's to say you
know don't think of yourself as a rails
developer or as a ruby developer but
instead think of yourself as a software
engineer such that whatever ends up
being the right tool for the job and
that tool might be rails my tool of
might be Ruby might be something else
that's what you fundamentally use you
solve problems
in the world of software and right now
it might be very beneficial for you to
go climbing up this hill of learning
more about rails or more about Ruby but
eventually you will not be you can
imagine ten years from now you'll be
working on something and rails probably
won't be the tool you want to use ten
years from now
in fact I I would right now I actually
consider myself to be I love Ruby I love
rails
I think they're really awesome and
wonderful tools but I would be probably
pretty disappointed myself if I was a
rails developer ten years from now and
that was what I consider myself to be
I'm a rails developer you know when when
DHH was talking about the article about
COBOL programmers that you know there
are people still making money for banks
working on these super antiquated COBOL
applications you can bet that there will
still be rails apps ten years from now
and I'm sure that you'll probably all
the fetch a pretty penny you know
basically managing these ten-year-old
twelve-year-old fifteen-year-old rails
apps but is that fundamentally what you
want to be doing or is what you want to
be doing to solve problems with software
however those problems end up changing
and whoever those tools end up changing
the second piece of advice I want to
give besides keeping your identity small
is pretty obvious which is to explore
the terrain and exploring the terrain to
me it means more than just kind of you
know paying lip service to different
things okay I don't know what Kafka is
I'm gonna go to this talk I'm gonna go
to that talk
it means fundamentally to do things
you've never done before
okay it means to do things that are kind
of scary to you it means to take real
risks and when I say real risks I'm just
opposing that against fake risks which I
think are a real thing and something you
should caution yourself against a fake
risk is one where you actually retain
all of your safety all of your comfort
all of your prestige all of your
knowledge all of your abilities or it's
like you know what I'm still a really
awesome person everyone respects me I
know everything that I'm doing but I'm
also taking this risk no you're not no
you're not right the risk comes when you
give up you actually walk down the hill
and walking down a hill is uncomfortable
it's scary
it makes you nervous and if you're not
actually doing that then you're not
really taking a genuine risk another way
of saying this is go to Jango Khan don't
actually go to Django Prada probably
sucks but there's probably like if if
railsconf is the only conference you're
going through this year reflect on that
reflect on what that means whether it
means that you are actually taking risks
that are important so and finally of
course I think the most important part
of exploration is just to have fun and
when you let go of the idea that you
constantly need to be moving up and that
in fact it's okay to move down and to
take risks in a way that potentially
make it harder for you to get your job
done and that's okay and that and allow
yourself to have fun doing it and I
think that makes the whole process a lot
easier so that's it for me I'm a seed
Qureshi a software engineer on risk it
Airbnb if you're a senior software
engineer or a data scientist we're
always hiring and yeah thanks for
listening
[Applause]